so let's have a look at it together it
says a random variable X has a
probability density function given by
that where X is in the interval between
Norton to him okay I wish your brights
on this down there's gonna be important
right so I've got this f of X I'm gonna
write it with lowercase X's because I'm
slightly lazy and then I have a domain
restriction on X oh it's between not and
tip what's the mean or expected value of
x so you will get this question posed to
in in either form they'll say give me
the mean give me the expected value as
you can see they mean the same thing
okay they mean the same thing all right
now you can you can see right at the top
there okay
I was very like I could just have handed
you that formula right and just say just
use it in fact you don't need to know
anything about where it comes from but
for me like that's the opposite of
mathematics just using a formula because
you get told it so I just wanted to go
through that preamble so you knew where
it came from but now that we do know
where it comes from I can go ahead and
work out what the expected value is
using this formula here right the
expected value is I'm gonna form my
integral and then I'm just gonna you
know put my calculus hat on and then off
I go okay so for starters I need some
boundaries for this integral right 0 to
10 these are the start and end points of
my probability density function and then
what I put in to integrate here like
usually we're like okay integrate your
probability density function now if I'm
going from naught to 10 and if I just
put in this you already know what the
answer will be if you integrate a
probability density function over its
entire domain you should get one right
because that's all the probabilities
right but I'm not working out of
probability I'm working out and expected
values so that's why I'm going to put an
extra X in there which indicates me
multiplying the probability by the score
you remember us doing that five 10 15
etcetera okay great so there's the X and
then here comes the f of X 1 over 5
minus X 150 with respect to X there you
go so what I've done is I've said this
is how I'm going to work out my expected
value in
I can always forget where this came from
and just start doing the calculus on
this I reckon we can really do one more
thing to make it a little easier which
is you can see I've got a product here
at the moment product I don't have a
reverse product rule in my head so I'm
going to expand that out and then go
turn my term when I integrate that okay
so it looks to me I'm gonna get X on
five minus x squared on 50 fantastica
don't know what that dots doing there
and let's go for it okay integral of X
on five x squared and then I divided by
the two with the five that's already
that's why we get excellent square and
ten how about this guy
X X cubed over 150 fantastic and then
I'm gonna evaluate from naught to ten
looks good so far you know Christ
simplify this yeah I mean there's some
common factors here you know there's a
constant common factor and there's also
X common factors but I want to point out
like I actually was doing something
working myself and I noticed that you
don't save a huge amount of time I guess
this is where it pays attention the pace
it pays to pay attention to what your
function is and whether you get much
benefit out of it for example if I
factorize out this X I'm still gonna
have to substitute in a couple places
anyway so you know what I'm just gonna
use it as it is upper boundary then
lower boundary yeah so here comes the
upper boundary ten squared on 10 take
away ten cute on 150 right there's my
upper boundary I'm not quite there yet I
haven't finished this bit yet even
though like it's not going to matter but
because I've got zero here as frequently
happens I think it is still important to
show like he's my upper boundary he's my
lower boundary that's what definite
integrals have and then I'm gonna go for
it okay someone already pop this into
the calculator
Sarang I think you said you hadn't I
can't read it can you tell me mine minus
50 over three that sounds wrong ten over
three ten over three sounds more like it
okay now just real real quick right I
didn't know what the answer was but I
knew it wasn't minus 50 over three and
your calculator
is gonna hand you numbers all the time
you have to be able to like to look at
them and instantly know like that's
ridiculous why is that ridiculous its
negative right like the values I'm gonna
get are going to be when you have a look
at this function right between Noir and
10 you can even think to yourself where
is this going to cure at naught you're
going to be here 1 over 50 at 10 you're
gonna be at 10 and 50 so it goes from
from one down to sorry 1 over 5 down to
zero right so you're never gonna get
into negatives yes so that's why you're
like okay I know that's not gonna be it
okay be happy with that that makes sense
now I did say and I'd love you to just
um you don't need to do this for the
question but let's just quickly draw up
what this looks like okay and I even did
have to work for you you've got a
y-intercept there at 1 over 5 and it has
a very very gentle negative gradient to
see it out 1 over 50 ok so it's gonna go
all the way down very slowly and it's
going to collide with here when I do x
equals 10 you get 1/5 minus 10 over 50
that's 1/5 minus 1/5 yeah so this value
10 is where my intercept is okay now
I've gotten this 10 over 3 what's that
as a mixed numeral that's like three and
a third right so if I call that 5
halfway so three thirds about here right
so what I'm saying is in there that's
where my mean will be you're like ah
that actually makes sense to me because
the main should be like I've got more
scores around here it's more probability
less scores around here so it makes
sense I'm I'm on this side of halfway
you happy with that